hello i'm greg sadler the editor of the
stoicism today blog a member of the
modern stoicism organization team and
the co-editor of a new book that we have
out that i want to
tell you about and put on your radar
it is stoicism today selected writings
volume three
just out this last month and you see the
beautiful cover this is a little bit
different you notice the not for resale
this is the proof that i got as the last
part of the editorial process both my
co-editor leah goldrick and i got one of
these and had to go over them and
correct any last things but this is what
the volume actually looks like if you
hold it in your hands it's you know
about 320
uh
eight pages of really high quality
articles
and discussions from the stoicism today
blog many of which have been revised and
expanded
and updated so i wanted to tell you
about this because it was a long process
to bring it to fruition we have 37
different pieces in this work each of
which involved contacting authors
getting them to send in their
manuscripts a lot of editorial work here
and there and this is the
final product so you can get this in
soft cover like what i'm holding in my
hand or you can get it from kindle in
that format either way
part of what you're doing in buying this
book
is supporting the work of the modern
stoicism ltd
non-profit organization the same
organization that brings you the blog
stoicism today and the modern stoicism
website and stoic week and stoic
mindfulness and resilience training and
the big stoicon conference with you know
all the videos available from that in
the modern stoicism youtube channel it's
it's a lot of stuff going on and it's
all done by
volunteers
like myself and are
more than a dozen other
team members so when you're purchasing
this about you know in the the soft
cover version about half of the purchase
price is going to helping people learn
about stoicism and apply it worldwide if
you purchase the kindle it's i think
it's a little bit more uh
percentage-wise but of course the kindle
version is cheaper because you don't
have to print out all these things
and i'm really proud of what we've
accomplished here
we have a number of you know major
authors in the field of modern stoicism
some of some of these are actually
entries from stoicon conferences for
example we have anthony long and
margaret graver
and julia anna some some really big name
authors and then we've got all sorts of
other
cool stuff that has been contributed so
i'm just going to like read through some
of the headings that we have because we
broke it up into a number of different
things we have first of all we begin
with something on modern stoicism
including the online symposium that we
had with this
modern stoicism team back then
and some other great articles then we
shift to stoic spiritual exercises
stoicism and physical eschesis stoicism
and the family
stoicism in the workplace stoicism and
medicine
a bit of comparative stuff with stoicism
and buddhism
stoicism and emotions stoicism and the
environment we have a controversy in
here and we're going to have some in
others later on about stoicism and
social justice stoicism connected with
other thinkers and we finish up with
stoicism and therapy and interpretation
of stoic theory
some really really
solid articles in here i think everybody
can learn from them i actually learned a
few things as i was going through and
editing them and i'm somebody who's been
studying stoicism for a very long time
so we also have you know beautiful cover
art by rochelle de torres um in in
consonance with the previous cover art
from the the earlier uh volumes and best
of all this is not the final volume this
is the first one that we've put out in a
number of years but we anticipate
bringing out stoicism today volume four
volume five and continuing on
so long as we have interesting
uh pieces about stoicism ancient and
modern to bring to you
readers who who might find this
worth checking out so i'll put links to
purchase the book below again remember
if you are purchasing this it's
contributing to the work of the
modern stoicism ltd nonprofit
organization that brings you stoicon
supports a lot of the stoicon x's
provides stoic week and other courses
and does so much work publicizing and
promoting stoicism around the world so
you know if you're interested in this i
will um put the table of contents as
well
into the video description so you can
see what's there you can also go to
amazon and click the show more and get
to see you know what's what's in the
book at least a little hint of it as
well so
don't want to make this too long
stoicism today selected writings volume
3 check it out maybe consider getting it
can be a great gift not only for
yourself that you give to yourself but
also for others who might be interested
in a wide spectrum discussion
and analysis and applications
of
stoic philosophy and practice
you